une canne françois lyotard petit
décompte 6 5 4 3 je suis ministre vous
avez appris comme tout le monde ce soir
la libération de roger auque et jean
louis normandin
quelle est votre réaction personnelle
était dans une immense salle immense
satisfaction
et j'allais dire un cru encore par le
fait qu'il s'agit de journalistes
j'ai eu l'occasion déjà de dire que
lorsqu'on essaie de prendre des
journalistes otages c'est bien qu'on
s'attaque à la liberté même de la pensée
et de la formation
et donc c'est une joie qui est pour moi
doublé par mes fonctions actuelles qui
consistent bien sûr à protéger cette
liberté c'est aussi de soucis très trash
de faire en sorte que maintenant on
gagne des autres on arrive à réussir
pour les autres parce que on ne peut pas
rester dans cette situation save et au
fil du temps ont malgré tout tous les
efforts que fait m 2 pour rappeler en
permanence y à juste titre cette
situation intolérable vient petit à
petit les gens s'habituent
donc je crois que c'est bien que vous
continuiez en parler et que la chaîne
continue à en parler que l'ensemble des
français se disent c'est notre affaire
c'est notre affaire à chacun parce que
ce sont les français et parce que ce
sont des journalistes souvent exposé que
vous considérez que c'est un succès
parce que c'est aussi un succès pour le
gouvernement
vous savez j'espère que c'est évident au
gouvernement va mettre tous ses efforts
pour faire ce travail cette action là
elle est nécessairement indiscrètes sur
eux comment du gouvernement bien sûr que
je serai là pour les accueillir
c'est pour moi une grande satisfaction
mais vous savez c'est lui préfère que ça
soit l'ensemble de la communauté
nationale qui se réjouissent
on n'a jamais fait c'est à faire quelque
chose d'autre qu'un vaste reste projet
national pour que tout le monde se soit
se sont associés à ce cas